as their dining rooms remain closed in
many parts of the country restaurants
are more reliant than ever on a handful
of delivery apps to stay afloat but
while convenient for consumers those
services come with big fees for
restaurants that have now caught the eye
of regulators
it's a consequential time for an
industry we reported on just a few
months back when we profiled GrubHub and
the humble beginnings of the company
that helped revolutionize delivery four
months later it looks like more change
is on the table
brook silva-braga reports ok with
everything this was white maize in
January a bustling venezuelan spot in
brooklyn new york now like so many
restaurants they've stacked tables in a
corner and waited for take-out business
that hasn't quite come so owner Cathy
Valera counts on delivery rain always
maybe o88
that has given new importance to the
delivery apps she's been using for years
Oh different all different apps a few
months ago she told us the apps
especially GrubHub had helped save her
restaurant by dramatically increasing
sales love has become dependence and
with so much of her business now coming
through the apps paying a 20% Commission
to GrubHub doesn't seem like such a
great deal anymore we paid too much in
commissions the feeling is widely shared
Washington DC Seattle and San Francisco
have all capped the Commission's
delivery apps can charge during the
pandemic at 15% many restaurants had
been paying twice that that's a high
cost to any small restaurant last week
City Councilman Francisco Moya passed a
commission cap in New York City when you
see something it sucks the blood out of
anything you call them leeches and that
is exactly what GrubHub is and how many
people do you now have in this building
we have probably a thousand rub hubs
rise love it or hate it starts with Matt
Malone evening the co-founder and
current CEO this past winter he watches
through Chicago I mean all the game I
would circle the streets and go to every
restaurant you're just going
door-to-door
yeah and take their paper menus rub calm
at least a version of it for part of
Chicago went live way back in 2004 it
was like a repository for menus that
delivered to you that was dynamic based
on where you were customers found that
ordering on an app was easier than a
phone call
restaurants learned the app was where to
find customers but at a price
some restaurants say that they described
it as a necessary evil they say I have
to be on these platforms because there's
business there but I already have thin
margins and now they're shrunk to almost
nothing on our platform its incremental
for the restaurants the majority of the
orders are incremental we see that when
they come on the platform their orders
skyrockets you have consumers that are
on the platform's looking for food
they're not walking down the street
online food ordering proved to be such a
compelling idea billions of dollars of
venture capital investors I've tried to
topple GrubHub doordash is now the
biggest food ordering app uber eats is a
major player to now drop up just want it
to be a kind of Yellow Pages for food
taking a fee to drum up business
but when competitors started making
actual deliveries GrubHub did that too
and it's led to massive financial losses
for all of them
uber eats lost over 450 million dollars
in q4
Amanda Clute is the editor-in-chief of
eater calm this whole thing isn't really
sustainable the restaurants are barely
making money the apps aren't making
money the consumers are getting an
unrealistic expectation of this good
that they are getting is that the
problem we're happy to take these
deliveries but it's just not a business
I don't think it's a great business
venture capital is paying for it right
now but the consumer
does not understand the real cost of it
the cost may be getting too great for
the apps uber is reportedly in talks to
buy GrubHub but when similar rumors were
leads in January
Maloney knocked them down are you open
to a sale we're currently not in a
process and we are no we have no
intention of being in a process to sell
the company so much has changed since
Maloney gathered those menus in 2004
even hometown Chicago is considering
regulating fees
in response GrubHub wrote to the City
Council this proposed cap will lower
order volume to restaurants and raise
costs to customers we're back in
Brooklyn
Cathy Valera is anxiously awaiting New
York's pandemic commission cap to be
signed into law Wayne how so it could be
as soon as next week I'm happy for them
do you know how much more money that'll
mean for you like seven thousand eight
thousand a month your pocket
of course it's gonna be for me no one
smiling
I'm just happy there's a good good news
at least for now that may be the hardest
thing to deliver for CBS this morning
Saturday
brook silva-braga New York it's tough
there right much I mean 20% 20% is a lot
so we'll see what happens
but for the consumer my son being one of
them it is the only way he eats right
now and I'm telling you not even in my
kitchen or my refrigerator does he go